so
i like starting off every interview with
like a little bit of a curveball i'm not
sure if you have the answer to this but
i'm going to try
if you could get the financing together
for any dream project
what would you make and why i think
interestingly
when you're when you're making something
it's when you
kind of find a character and a story
that
i always think has a bit of edge and a
bit of punk and a bit of
a bit of spike to it i i think i'm
always drawn to characters who are a
little bit extreme
and so if you can find those stories
then then that's a good starting place
for
for ex for making something
my my mind went straight to
things that i love um you know movies of
mine that i love but
the remake's never as good um so i'm
gonna say i don't know and
and that's the best thing um is that i
don't know because
you want to create a movie that is not
out there um
and you know it's it's uh it's an
endless pc
somewhere sure jumping into why i get to
talk to you guys today uh first of all
congratulations on the film
i am curious i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making
of projects so what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of this film
we had dancing lessons
i know we just look like natural dancers
um
definitely we had to do hours of
training three hours of training
um how to dance
i don't know maybe maybe our dancing was
already like too cool
exactly we had to learn how to dance
badly it was really hard for us
yeah i did not expect that answer the
interesting thing about this movie is
that
for you guys like half the movie you
weren't there for when it was shooting
so what was it like watching the
finished film for the first time because
literally half the film you know doesn't
involve you guys
well augustine would show us little bits
of what they'd already shot and we're
showing us pictures and
would make us really jealous by showing
us pictures of
shailene and callum just reclining on
yachts and
we would think how sad we were to be in
a basement
shooting for hours on end so we had a
pretty good sense of what they were
doing
it was great to watch the finished
product because
yeah we got little glimpses but no it
was it was so extraordinary and
and that timeline and those beautiful
images and scenery that is
so much to the film um you know it kind
of
you know the two worlds complemented
each other so yeah i also enjoyed it
uh for both of you i am curious what was
it about this script and story that said
i want to do this i loved initially just
loved
ellie and the character and and doing
something humorous and modern
and um it felt like something different
that i hadn't done for
for a while and and then
it was the idea of something romantic
um but in the hands of augustine who
would bring an
edge and and would make sure that it
wasn't sentimental or soppy it felt like
that
combination was was was a film that i
would quite like to see myself
to me it was the the writing and the
characters is the first thing
you know you're exposed to in reading
the script
and yeah i loved worry i loved ellie
you know i found her so refreshing i
really wanted to
to follow her story um i really wanted
her to succeed when i was you know i was
reading the script and following her
character
and um i just love how ellie and rory
fall for each other that note i got to
stop i'm just going to say
again congrats on the film i hope you
guys uh enjoy the rest of your speed
dating today
thank you so much cheers thank you